I hate interviewing people because they
very rarely level with you,
and so although it would be interesting
to sit down with Joseph Stalin and say
on earth,
did you delude yourself about Nazi plans
for the invasion of the Soviet Union in
1941 and nearly destroy your own
country?
I don't think he would tell me the truth
on balance.
As an historian,
I've always chosen the dead over the
living for the very good reason that
they're.
That letters and diaries are far prefer
to what they might have told me in an
interview.
So if you forced my hand,
I'd probably.
I would probably like to spend some time
with Stalin even though he was probably
the most frightening man of the 20th
century.
Most people who've spent time with him
were filled with fear through
throughout.
Still,
it would be a.
It would be a fascinating experience.